this man is desperate for news of his
wife
and daughter he hopes rescuers will find
them alive
in this huge pile of debris they've been
missing since last friday's magnitude
7.0 earthquake that shook turkey's west
coast city of izmir efforts continue to
rescue as many people as possible
with the help of sniffer dogs while
clusters of this road relatives
wait outside the flattened building
another building in the same district
where the ground is a wet clay according
to geology experts
and at risk of collapse its foundation
and first two floors have already sunk
into the ground
the planet
the magnitude of this earthquake wasn't
very high but it shows
how weak our buildings are bad concrete
which immediately turns into sand
or debris at these two or three columns
used on the first floor reportedly
removed
to make room before the earthquake
experts here tell us that this building
is another example of poor quality
construction
cranes are holding parts of it in place
until it's safe enough to demolish the
structure
friday's earthquake struck some parts of
neighboring greece as well
both countries sit on major fault lines
people in izmir have been experiencing
hundreds of aftershocks
that continue to shake their city parks
have become a temporary shelter for some
it was a strong earthquake we were so
afraid there was no damage in our
building
although it's 40 years old but our
children are scared
that's why we're staying in a tent until
a full damage assessment can be carried
out across the city
people may have to stay in tents like
these for days to come
cenazolo al jazeera izmir western turkey